the thing about this obviously
this is based on your material it's
based on a trilogy of books
and i'm curious how did you guys decide
how the because the movie is different
than the books in terms of the plot and
there's a whole bunch of things that are
different how did you decide
the sort of changes you know what i mean
you know known as a big question but
uh could you sort of talk about that
well my starting premise
always in adapting any work but
including my own is that a movie is a
remix
it's never going to be an exact thing
it's not a cover version it's you know
it's a remix you're changing it to suit
the needs of what a film has to have
and so it becomes a long long
conversation and because the book is
about 500 pages long there's just a lot
of incident
that couldn't possibly be in a two-hour
film it's a hundred and four hundred and
ten minutes something like that
um and so you start from the beginning
thinking well what's important what's
essential
and what's always essential is the
themes of it and the relationships
and the actual events are you find are
not quite so important
as long as the key ones are there so
i personally don't mind the changes i i
expect them the book remains um but
it's a long conversation and seeing what
fits and what's right along the way was
it ever
radically different in terms of how you
were going to do things or you know talk
about that initial
genesis of the writing process not not a
ton
i mean the the the main challenge was
how the noise was going to be portrayed
and that was the thing that occupied
most of the creative conversations
because
you know we felt the story was pretty
good uh the cast came on pretty early so
we knew
how everyone would look and feel you
know be embodied and what tom
holland and daisy ridley would need and
you know what their strengths are
it was the most of the creative
conversations were about
what does thought look like and how can
it not look
a mess and how can it not look cheap and
how can it absolutely positively
seem to reflect what someone's thinking
and that those were the very those are
the longest creative conversations and
i'm glad that they were because like
there's a scene in the movie
just a quick one where daisy really is
walking up a hill and tom allen is
behind her and he's grumpily thinking
about her and all of his thoughts are
just sort of being cast off the back of
his head that we can see
and to me that's perfect and all those
conversations led to that
so uh yeah so that that's really it
wasn't so much about
how we'd radically change it it was like
how are we going to make this work
so that people understand it how much
time did you spend
uh casting manche how involved did you
want to be in that
uh i got sent some pictures and i had uh
you know i as
as the author and screenwriter the thing
that i tried to do most is be
friendly and sane and uh and i find that
when you are that you get a lot more
creative involvement
um and so i just i you know i said well
this is how i pictured menchie this is
uh particularly the size of manche um
because he is a particular size
um and then doug lyman i got sent a
whole bunch of casting photos of doug
lyman playing with dogs
and and this winston was the winston was
the right match
i'm curious i know that you're involved
with snowblind and anya's ghost
uh can you give updates on those
projects i can't give one on his ghost
uh but on snowblind i am writing it now
and uh working with jake gyllenhaal's
production company who are great great
people
and with a director called gustav muller
so it's in the writing stages um
and yeah got a deal at apple so i mean
fingers crossed it's
it shoots in the snow so it's one of
those tricky ones but um we're hoping
hope and hope and open for maybe later
this year for this coming up winter
yeah that's what i'm curious about you
can usually from what i understand i'm
not obviously in these meetings but
you can usually understand from what i
unders from what i've been told
how much a studio wants to make
something based on how many how often
they're calling you to get updates or
whatever do you get the vibe that snow
blind is something that you know they
really want to make this year
um well i mean again timing is all
dependent on writing and everybody
agreeing getting a schedule but i
um get very much get the feeling uh that
apple wants to make it i mean apple is
really interested in making movies
and not not just everybody's got to fill
up their streaming service but they
are the movies that they're choosing in
the movies that they're
putting themselves behind feel really
interesting to me and they were
very very keen on this and have remained
so so
i as optimistic as you can be in
hollywood um which is
iffy but uh but you know i have i have
nothing but good feelings for it
last question for you uh you write a lot
of books and i'm curious
how are you managing your time what
books are you working on right now
uh i was raised by a military father a
lovely man he didn't force it on us or
anything but
he his example was just protestant
scandinavian work ethic and so
um i just get a lot done over the course
of a day and also
i my books took off when i was in my
late 30s and so
i know that success is luck and
ephemeral and it's timing
so while i have opportunities i want to
take them so i i work really hard
i had a new book out last year called
burn um
i'm not sure what book i'm going to
write next but i'm working on snow blind
and i'm adapting lord of the flies for
luca guadagnino
so um i'm busy i'm busy yeah i could i
could ask a whole bunch of questions on
lord of the flies but i gotta go
and i'm just gonna say uh congrats on
everything i wish you nothing but the
best
thank you very much indeed